now the international center for
journalists holds its 25th anniversary
dinner keynote speaker is david rohde
pulitzer prize-winning investigative
journalist for The New York Times he was
kidnapped by the Taliban in Afghanistan
but escaped after seven months in
captivity while he was held the New York
Times and other media outlets withheld
news of his kidnapping this event is 45
minutes before we hand over the podium
to Seymour Hersh I'm pleased to announce
that I cfj is flying to name an award in
his honor in the coming year a night
fellow will be in the Middle East to
establish investigative teams at news
organizations there I cfj and its
partner Arab reporters for Investigative
Journalism will choose the best story to
receive the seymour hersh investigative
journalism award please give a warm
round of applause now Christina
um
thank you but
I was going to make fun I had a lot of
fun planned for Holbrook I've known for
40 years who once was the Hillary once
Clinton once actually I will tell you
this story she once described dick
Holbrook this is a during the campaign
last year as the only person in America
who could be talking to my husband at a
cocktail party and be looking behind in
the sewer see who else is there but
anyway I would have done too much
because he's lost a sense of humor years
ago if I had his if I had his job I
would have to so i i'm i'm sort of i let
me tell you what's so impressive about
this um you're talking to somebody who
was born a from lower middle class
Eastern European family my parents came
without education they didn't get to
high school my mother was actually clean
houses I didn't pay for school I when I
went to the original shock all go I
minimal money and 11 years after
graduating from college I as a freelance
reporter I'm sticking two fingers in
1969 into the eye of a sitting American
president a republican richard nixon and
describing the mass murder as you heard
in me lie to a nation that really had
been in ered to the consequences of war
we were we were world war two was
sanitized for us we really hadn't come
to grips with the fact that the truth be
that alas american soldiers not
surprisingly fight wars no better or
worse than any other armies it's always
the last resort it's always brutal it's
always about payback revenge for your
buddy it's not about the flag and so I
do this story in 69 and I get fame
fortune glory I get more money than ever
seen before enough to put a down payment
on the house I get prizes like the
Pulitzer Prize and you say to yourself
what a special place you have to say to
yourself this country is no matter what
this is a country in which you can the
First Amendment as I said
is there much it no matter how much you
hear about how much they don't like us
and so I'm a strong believer that we're
not going to be saved ultimately by
politicians who always make political
judgments even in cases of war life and
death and more it's always political I
believe we may have an exception with
this president but we haven't seen it
yet we may because we all have a lot of
hope but you know I don't know how
Holbrook was going to spin holbrook
Afghan tonight you know a dart light at
the end of the tunnel led by Karzai but
he was going to try so anyway here here
you come I come from this this notion
that we have this amazing sort of power
this amazing right we don't often do a
good job I don't have to tell you after
911 instead of standing outside and
holding George Bush to the highest
standard possible we were jingoistic we
fell in line we didn't ask some of the
questions one of the questions that
later occurred to me about 911 we
learned at some point that September the
11th was the date plan by Al Qaeda all
powerful mystical all-knowing omniscient
al Qaeda but I always started thinking
and was years later I asked myself one
day suppose September the 11th had been
like today raining cold cloudy what
would happen to those guys hijacking in
other words we didn't ask the right
questions about WMD obviously even about
Al Qaeda and so but we're there that we
we are really I think more than any
other unit in this in our society in in
the Congress even in the judiciary we
have some terrible decisions just made
the other day and in the Second Circuit
in the case of the Canadian we are there
and we have a and tonight I gotta tell
you listening to sue shoe and listening
to this reminds me again that if we're
going to get a salvation in the world
and I actually have had similar
experience I've spent a lot of time
literally a three four five six visits
in the last few years talking the
journalists in the Middle East and the
difference between what they do what sue
shoe does and what I do is the word
courage has nothing to do with what i do
i do it and I'm exalted they do it and
they run risk what what the
International Center is doing and I'm
making a pitch for them I don't even
know him that well I'm just telling you
it's essential because I have spoken I
was in Cairo and I spoke to a 60
journalists off the record Mohammed
Heikal the great wonderful some of you
may know the great wonderful journalist
of Egypt had me in in his retirement
he's put money into a fund to encourage
investigative reporting I spoke to 50 or
60 journalists many of them half of them
woman half of them were in the islamic
garb all had the same thing they wanted
to know for me how do they expose
corruption how do they expose wrongdoing
how can they get into military secrets
and they were coming to me they were
from Egypt they were from Yemen they
were 11 on they were from other places
in the Middle East all of them were
listening to me expound about how to do
this and that the only difference being
their reporting was going to lead the
jeopardy for them mine doesn't we live
in a very special place and so we really
have to support this kind of stuff
because I'm going to tell you if there's
going to be a change in in in the in the
world we live in I think we and our
colleagues in Europe in the Middle East
in Africa and the Far East are going to
have much more to do it with it than any
political leadership in fact I would
argue the political leadership is going
to drive it the other way clearly that
we've seen in the last eight years how
much backwards farther much farther
backwards we've gone if that's English
instead of blue perfect German anyway so
the message is real simple what do we
offer but we offer you is people say to
me what do you do what you do and let me
tell you my theory of journalism it's
really pretty simple I i I'm a parent I
live with my
significant other I have children I
don't trust is the core of the
relationship I don't lie to my children
I don't want to lie I don't want them to
lie to me I used to say occasionally
with the exception of 13 to 15 year old
girls but I stop saying that because I
get too many hisses but in Berkeley but
anyway but the point is quite seriously
so in my personal life what do i do my
personal life like all of us everywhere
on the world we want we want respect and
trust in our intimate relationships and
truth-telling and in this country
particularly given the president's we
had Johnson Nixon Bush the same sort of
demands and requirements that we make
and we insist on having we must have in
our personal life we don't begin to ask
of our national leaders those people
have the right to send our sons and
daughters to die in the name of
democracy we don't begin to hold them to
the same standards we hold our immediate
family members do and when you when you
start realizing the extent to which it's
a bad bargain for us that we don't that
we we make a distinction between what
something that's so important to us a
life and we shrug off the inability to
always believe our national leaders what
can I say that's that's our job our job
is to hold these people always always
even the ones we respect and may rêveur
you know they really really adore like
our current president many of us do we
must hold them to the highest possible
standards and that's what it's all about
thank you so much it's a great honor
Thank You Seymour truly an extraordinary
figure in American journalism to
commemorate ICF Jays 25th anniversary
and to congratulate this evenings
winners we now have a special greeting
from someone who needs no introduction
although actually she had one earlier in
another video let's go to the videotape
I am honored to join you in celebrating
the 25th anniversary of the
International Center for journalists and
the work of journalists you support in
more than 170 countries worldwide too
often the most grave injustice a--'s and
most urgent humanitarian crises happen
out of sight well tonight's award
winners have helped to shine a spotlight
on situations that demand action from
all of us and in doing so they have
helped to make our world a better safer
and more equitable place for more than
40 years sy Hersh has been uncovering
the stories we all need to know from his
reporting of the meal I Massacre to his
coverage of US policy in the Middle East
his reporting compels us to ask tough
but necessary questions about our
responsibilities to other people and
nations chuchu nama gabay not been to a
courageous radio journalist whom I met
in August has broken the silence on
sexual and gender-based violence used as
a tool of war and the Democratic
Republic of Congo and we need to make
sure her voice is heard and 28 year old
reporter sajan woo has encouraged other
young people to think critically about
the role of government and engage in the
work of civil society so this
organization is critical to ensuring the
integrity of democratic societies around
the globe the world is counting on you
to keep up your good work in the years
to come and so am I thank you all very
much
thank you madam secretary it's now my
honor to introduce Michael golden the
vice chairman of the New York Times
Company and of ICF J to introduce our
evening speaker Michael golden do a
brief bit of time travel with me take
yourself back to the first week of April
this year when flowers were just
beginning to spring the leaves were just
coming out on the trees school was still
in full session and we moved into May
school ended there was June that pretty
damp month and then the wonderful summer
that we had through July the day lazy
days of August September the school
cycle the business cycle picks up again
then October and we come through the
month the leaves start to fall and we
find ourselves here tonight that's the
period of time that David road was held
in captivity by the Taliban seven months
and 10 days David was named in 2002 the
co-chief of the South Asia Bureau of the
New York Times he reported on the
peacekeeping efforts in Iran in
Afghanistan he reported on the
earthquake in northern Pakistan that
killed 75,000 people and while he was
held in captivity he was one of a team
of New York Times reporters who received
the 2009 Pulitzer for their reporting on
Afghanistan and Pakistan that was not
David's first Pulitzer in 1996 when he
worked for the Christian Science Monitor
he was awarded a Pulitzer for
international reporting on the Bosnian
war crimes he was in fact at the age of
28 the first Western reporter that went
into the Bosnian Serb territory and
discovered evidence of genocide and mass
graves and his hard work there was
rewarded with ten days of imprisoned
relentless interrogation accusations of
spine by the Serbian authorities it was
efforts by international reporters
organizations like this NGOs it finally
rewarded him with his release he wrote a
book about that called n gain the
betrayal of fall the betrayal and fall
of Sabrina coup that was published in
1997 to to rave reviews and today he is
working on a book on Afghanistan and
Pakistan I just can't tell you what a
pleasure it is to welcome David back
with us here tonight David
um thank you so much it's a wonderful to
be here on many levels and I i'll do my
best night this is actually my first
time publicly speaking about the time I
spent captivity and Afghanistan and
Pakistan last year I first want to thank
Michael golden the New York Times was
incredibly supportive to me and my
family throughout this entire period
it's an
in a in a frankly economically
devastating times for the news industry
the that newspaper continues to invest
and it's in its new staff it continues
to have reporters out on the ground
reporting around the world and I think
we all know that's just absolutely
invaluable for us to continue the public
service that sy Hersh was was just
speaking about and I just thank them
from the bottom my heart for supporting
my family so much secondly I want to if
I want to thank my wife who's here she
she married me two months before I
managed to get myself kidnapped and you
you know you might question that
decision but to my amazement she never
did and one of the things that kept me
going the most was a we were able to
exchange letters at one point via the
International Red Cross and she wrote a
simple message to me which was you must
remain strong because I am strong and
I'd appreciate it if you'd throughout
their Kristen if you could stand up
and secondly and this is I'll get to the
address i promise i also want to
recognize a very close friend of mine
and a wonderful colleague abdul wahid
Wafaa is our most senior afghan
journalist from New York Times Bureau
and Kabul he and the you know would
winners tonight are an example of what
really matters and why ICF Jays work is
so vital it's it's local journalists
that make a difference in all these
countries it's local journalists that
are going to help stabilize these
societies not foreign correspondence and
I'm so proud to work with why he'd
separately another Afghan journalist
Tahir louddon was kidnapped with me he's
also a reason I'm here tonight I never
would have been able to escape from
captivity without him and unfortunately
after ty here and I were able to escape
a second New York Times reporter and
another Afghan journalist from our staff
were also kidnapped in Afghanistan and I
just would ask you to also recognize
Sultan Menotti who died in a rescue
effort that did free Stephen Farrell but
unfortunately still tom was killed if
what you could just stand up I just want
to recognize all the journalists who
perished in the last year
so you've been promised a keynote
address and you were promised ambassador
Holbrooke and instead you've got me I
promise you that I won't sit here and
read word for word every part of the
five-part series that appear in the New
York Times and I suspect that many of
you didn't read everywhere this series I
probably wouldn't have read it myself
and those of you who did I thank you
from the bottom of my heart what I want
to do is is simply tell that story i'm
not sure what else going to do is a
journalist and describe the really
complex and difficult realities i found
among the Taliban and and the
difficulties you know this country faces
at this point and the difficulties
Afghans and Pakistanis face so I'll just
try to quickly run through a narrative
of what occurred to me for people that
have already heard some of this in the
series I apologize to you and then I'll
you know be happy to sit down with
Georgia take questions and I just hope
we can basically spark a conversation
here about an enormously difficult and
dangerous situation I was kidnapped just
about an hour outside of Kabul we've
been invited to an interview by a
Taliban commander that had given
interviews to two other foreign
journalists in hindsight you know
obviously was a mistake to have gone to
that interview what surprised me was we
were simply an hour outside of Kabul and
after we were kidnapped the Tollan were
able to move us across hundreds of miles
of territory in Afghanistan we drove at
one point for two days straight and
during that entire stretch of time
across the Afghan countryside we didn't
see a single Afghan policemen or any
sort of foreign or Afghan soldier we
were smuggled over the border into the
tribal areas of Pakistan which has been
written about a great deal but very few
people fortunately many fairy few
foreigners have not been brought there I
was amazed by what I found in the tribal
areas as we drove down the roads there
every Pakistani
and check post have been abandoned
instead taliban check posts lined the
road thriving inside of pakistan today
is a taliban mini-state the taliban
regime that many believe the united
states had toppled in 2001 is alive and
well today despite the deaths of
thousands of Americans Afghans and
Pakistanis it simply moved a few miles
east I found a world where my guards
felt so much freedom and such confidence
that they strolled the streets and
chatted with Arab and foreign militants
in miram shah the capital of North
Waziristan they spent their days taking
bomb-making classes from Uzbek militants
learn how to make roadside bombs that
they would then cross over the border
and set off in Afghanistan and they
watched endless amounts of propaganda
videos that were enormously effective at
creating an alternate universe that the
Taliban lived in the top I mini-state I
found had its own police ahead its own
road crews and schools it's a fully
functional state that is operating
inside the borders of our purported Ally
Pakistan I and I describe this to you in
such detail because I was alarmed by
what I discovered there my guards talked
about their their burning desire to
travel the United States and carry out
suicide attacks here they believed that
the United States is waging a religious
war against Islam and that tens of
thousands of Muslim civilians are being
slaughtered across the world in from
Palestine to Iraq to obviously
Afghanistan itself the American effort
to portray this as a war on terrorism
appears to have early failed and I was
shocked by the beliefs of the guards and
people I live with then I mentioned this
earlier and I'm happy to talk about the
QA what surprised me most was that
particularly in the tribal areas young
after
and pakistanis who I believe would be
Taliban primarily focused on only the
situations in Pakistan and Afghanistan
had spent a great deal of time in the
tribal areas with foreign militants and
their views had shifted they very much
saw themselves as part of a global jihad
they very much to saw themselves as
working alongside al Qaeda an effort to
establish a hard-line state that would
span the Islamic world and I want to add
a very large caveat here I was in
Waziristan which is you know arguably
the most dangerous part of the tribal
air is full of the most hardline
Islamists and militants there are many
other Taliban in Afghanistan that may be
primarily focused simply on control of
Afghanistan and driving American enforce
American and foreign forces out of
Afghanistan but I can't begin to tell
you how troubled I was by the vehemence
of the hatred I found the United States
among young Afghans young Pakistanis and
and their reverence almost four Shaikh
Osama as they called him they saw
themselves as part of a great historic
movement that was going to liberate the
Muslim world from oppression I live with
a suicide bomber for about five or six
weeks he was amused by me he saw the
West as a decadent culture bent on
enriching itself and forcing Muslims to
give up their culture in their religion
he believed that a necktie was a secret
symbol of Christianity he asked me if it
was true that all Christians want to
live for a thousand years he believed
that the United States military was
caring about excuse me carrying out
forcible conversions of Muslims across
Afghanistan and Iraq and he believed
that Afghan women were being forced into
prostitution across Afghanistan
obviously that's a very bleak picture
but I want to be honest with you with
what I found there I also found some
skepticism among my guards they viewed
some of their commanders
as more interested in money than energy
HOD but overall it was a very disturbing
and sad state in terms of their view of
the war on terror and the United States
his goal in Afghanistan and Pakistan
myself and tie here after seven months
in captivity had realized that our
captors weren't seriously negotiating
for our release we decided our only way
to ask it to to end our captivity and
the suffering of our families was to try
to escape I won't go into the detail
here but we were extraordinary lucky to
get out and we were I want to point out
saved when we went to a Pakistani
military base we climbed a wall at night
out of the house from being held captive
and it was Pakistani moderates Pakistani
members of the local militia that took
us on their base and saved our lives so
I walk away from this experience you
know surprised and disappointed by the
depth of the hatred and the cynicism and
the the harsh fundamentalism I found
among some Afghans and Pakistanis but
also touched by the bravery and
moderation I found among other Afghans
and Pakistanis in one sense in Afghan
one Afghan lied to me and kidnapped me
and held me captive for seven months
another one Tahir helped me escape and
saved my life today kidnapping continues
in Afghanistan and Pakistan the Akane
Network the group that kidnapped me and
operates in Waziristan continues to
operate there are serious questions
about the Pakistani military commitment
to confront the hakan ease some
Pakistani officials describe the hakan
ease and the Taliban is a strategic
asset that Pakistan should continue to
use to counter India and Afghanistan and
I'll just finish with a final anecdote
and please remember I'm not disclosing
any names tonight but there are still
journalists local and foreign and many
many other people many average their
average Pakistanis and Afghans still
being held tonight prisoner in the
tribal areas this problem has not been
solved and we were extremely
extraordinary lucky to escape and others
will not be and the simplest anecdote
that i can think of describes the
breadth of the problem we face there and
to be honest I understand the
frustration and skepticism about what
the United States can achieve in
Afghanistan and Pakistan but I also
don't think it's it's possible for us to
simply walk away thousands of afghans
and Pakistanis frankly 5,000 Afghans and
roughly the same number of Pakistanis
have died fighting the Taliban since
2001 and as a widespread expectation
among Afghans and Pakistanis at the
United States will again abandon the
region as they did after the Sylvia
troops withdrew in 1989 lastly one of
our one of my last houses we were kept
in his prisoners at one point I met a
young boy who was a student at a local
school run by the Akane network he told
me that he did his sores and got money
from his parents for doing his chores
and he was donating some of his money
each week to a local fund for suicide
bombers it was the thing to do for young
kids was to to to somehow help fund the
purchase of materials for suicide
bombings and I then asked the young boy
what did he want to be when he grew up
and he said his first answer was you
know first that I want to be a fettig in
a suicide bomber and I said oh come on
come on you must have some other goal
for what you'd want to be use when
you're up what's your second choice and
he said well I want to be a Mujahideen I
want to be a holy warrior and then I
said well what what's your third choice
come on there must be something else you
want to be you know a doctor a teacher
something like that and he said I want
to be a Muslim and I lead with that
story I apologize for not having a more
uplifting message tonight but it is an
extraordinarily difficult and dangerous
situation
and the tribal areas that is disabling
is in both Afghanistan and Pakistan and
I hope we can now the conversation that
will shed light on these issues and what
role the United States you know could or
can play in that region thank you
thank you for sharing that with us this
is a real treat for me to get a chance
to talk to you about this I almost don't
know where to begin but I was a little
surprised when you were talking just at
the very end there when you said as she
gave a little bit of a prescription you
said we cannot walk away so let's take
it to the next step as the president is
trying to figure out what he in the
country should do even if you're not
willing to make a full-blown
prescription what's the the single most
important thing you would want him to
know before he makes a decision and the
single most important question you would
want him to ask I'll again stay away
from policy prescriptions Anna but based
on what i experienced there still are
many moderates in pakistan and
afghanistan that adamantly opposed the
Taliban and and surprisingly things in
Pakistan have gone fairly well in terms
of since the Taliban pushed into the
Swat Valley and we're close to his Lama
bought the army then did push them out
of that area many Pakistanis were
incredibly angry and they they
themselves started saying this isn't
Islam what the Taliban are doing these
are not this is not jihad they're
essentially criminals there's a massive
kidnapping network that I was part of
that includes many more Pakistanis and
the Taliban have sort of i think
undercut themselves in pakistan and it's
a good sign that i think more and more
Pakistanis are seeing that they're ill
so is on the downside of a widespread
perception the United States is
occupying Afghanistan and Iraq and it's
it's been said by many people but I
would just think a key thing is how do
you more consistently effectively and
quietly back local moderates in these
countries they're there and they're
there they're questioning our our
commitment at this time let me ask you
another question about your your own
store you talked a little bit about the
moment when you decided
to escape and I just wonder if you could
to lab elaborate on the decision a
little bit more I mean how much of it
was you really thought it was going to
work and how much of it was I just can't
take it anymore I didn't I never thought
I was going to work I had I thought I
would try and I feel better the next day
for Evan Dryden and then this sort of
you know our super duper caper consisted
the initial part of it was I was just
going to get up and go to the bathroom
so I I mean we had planned everything
out in a couple weeks earlier I had
found a car tow rope in the house was
being held it was next to some motor oil
and wrenches and and what prompted it
was a tower guards we were constantly
lied to about that there were
negotiations going on and they were they
promised they'd compromise and they just
given this is preposterous story to us
that the u.s. is going to trade
prisoners from Guantanamo Bay for us so
after that was thinking about all the
time planning something the power came
back on that night and we were just
exasperated and then on a personal level
I wanted to try because and this isn't a
very journalistic neutral last statement
but we had really come to hate our
captors we we saw there there was even a
hypocrisy playing out in front of me
we're taught here the journalist who's
with me would sit there and say this is
not as long you invited us to an
interview this is not Pashtunwali this
isn't how you treat guests and and there
was just we just we wanted to end the
suffering our families and we wanted
them to get nothing but and you thought
if you didn't succeed they wouldn't kill
you the next day throughout the
captivity they made it very clear they
would kill tahun Assad first and that
hatred towards Afghans and Pakistanis
that work with the United States is much
deeper than the hatred towards Americans
and they constantly said and this has
happened in past cases there was a
kidnapping an Italian journalist where
they killed the driver
later and then you know got a larger
ransom for the journalists so I didn't
feeling that much danger one member of
the economy family kept calling me the
golden hen expecting me play at a go
away which was never late and I'm so
happy and lucky to be here yeah you're
very clear in the article and the times
has been very clear that no ransom was
paid yet there's still some skepticism
sure out in the world about that i think
if some people find it hard to believe
that your captors just slept through the
night without any incentives i expect
you to repeat your denial but how does
it weigh how do you confront the
skepticism just that I don't know I
would never write a five part series
that was a lot just personally and this
newspaper would never run a series based
on a lot but I lived through and I know
what to hear lived through I've talked
ad nauseam to the Pakistani this young
captain lettuce on his base that night
no one was in the area he had no idea we
were coming it took them and I think it
took them eight or nine hours to get in
a helicopter to move us out of the base
and I know there's skepticism out there
but no money was paid there's been some
writing about an earlier plan and our
kidnapping to try to bribe our guards
there was information coming in about a
village we were being held in we were
never held in that village and you know
attempts were made to dragon information
while we were being held but they were
never able to make contact with you know
or frankly give money to anybody that
was actually living with us so you know
it's it's very rare but we were
extraordinary lucky and as I said
there's still many many other p
well there and one other thing is that
just for other journalists we fight this
rumor so hard because false stories like
this and could encourage future
kidnappings and from the bottom of my
heart no ransom was paid in this case
our guards were not bribed we escaped
and I I just it's the truth and I just I
don't want to see other journalists put
in danger because of false stories and I
regret you know what I didn't what
happened to me and don't want to cause
future problems for other people can you
imagine going back to report from there
I cannot imagine going back and
reporting from there and Kristen can
tell you I've already promised her that
my days is a war correspondent or over
there done my days and journalism were
not over but my days is a war
correspondent or over I just have a
couple more questions and we are running
late tonight but one of the things I was
most struck by you talk about how you
hated your captors you also write in the
articles about how they try to convert
you over time and you describe yourself
at the beginning of your captivity as
either non-practicing or a non-observant
Christian yet on the you also talked
about how over the course of your
captivity you pray to calm yourself down
and in fact on the night you escaped you
said God forgive me two thousand times I
think and I just wonder if you could
talk about that a little bit was this a
kind of conversion has it survived
coming home in terms of their efforts to
convert me the the more time I spent
with them and the more I saw Tiger argue
with them it became clear to me that and
it's overly simplistic but that Tiger
was the true Islam he was honest he was
you know he feared God you know he told
the truth and they did not they
incessantly lied to us they were frankly
greedy so one basic thing is to not sort
of seed Islam to them or in any way
shape or form think that they represent
this religion the vast number of Afghans
and Pakistanis who are
opposed to the Taliban are the majority
and the true Muslims and in terms of my
personal religious beliefs you know I
don't know if repeating a prayer during
the day is you know that this is some
greater being hears the prayer and
reaches down and you feel better
magically or if it's simply a
psychological trick that you know you
say these things and you feel centered
but it kept me going you know faith kept
me going and I'm still not i would say a
sort of practicing religious person but
it helped me get through this experience
finally and for all of you haven't read
the piece it really is worth every
second it takes to read it and
especially when you get to the end I
mean it was what was most moving to me
you talk about your first phone call
home to Kristin from that Pakistani
military base and you get on the phone
and you say Kristin and you write
savoring the chance to out of the words
I dreamed of saying to her for months
Chris and I said please let me spend the
rest of my life making this up to you
yes she said yes so how you doing on
that well
i would say about I don't know once
every week or two Kristen tourism and
says so I'm still waiting when is the
rest of my life going to start but I'm
extraordinary lucky to be home and so
grateful to Kristen and my family and
the newspaper for supporting me and and
so grateful for the again I hated my
captors you know I and I've been bias
now in terms of covering the Taliban
it's so grateful for the the Afghans and
Pakistanis that save my life and it's
it's all I'll say is I don't know the
answer but it's not so simple we can't
just walk away from these these
countries at this point thank you very
much thank
thank you very much David for sharing
your story I couldn't wait to get the
paper every day when it was running it
was an amazing story and were delighted
that you were able to share it with us
today and thanks to george as always for
being such a for a great discussion and
for being such a great host in a very
special year our 25th anniversary there
are a few people I have to thank for
their long time dedication to helping
journalists around the world I cfj has
an amazing board of directors and
throughout the year they help us make
connections raise funds and private
guidance and we just wanted to say a
special thank you to them we are very
grateful to them three board members in
particular have done so much for this
organization that all of us at ICF J
don't know what we do without them so
I'd like to ask I cfj chairman jim hogg
Vice Chair Pamela Howard and treasurer
Jack Hamilton to please stand
we'd like to offer you
we'd like to offer you a small token for
all that you do on our behalf over many
many years I'm also truly blessed with
the remarkable staff who worked so hard
throughout the year and I'd like to
thank the old sash doola Don RT Agha
Sharon Connell Amy Martin and joy marie
Mackenzie for organizing this dinner and
making it such a success one member of
the ICF J Steph Stan stands out in
particular Nancy fry joined I cfj 25
years ago to keep the books not cook the
books keep the books she is now our vice
president for finance and administration
and she really is the heart and soul of
ICF J so I wanted all of us wanted to
say a very special thank you to Nancy
for all you do for us
finally I'd like to thank the absolutely
stellar CBS team for producing the
amazing videos of our Award winners
special thanks goes to John Milloy Tony
Kevin Anthony Mason and especially CBS
producer Mark sterchi also leading the
CBS team for the fourth year in a row is
my wonderful sister Jacqueline bar
nathin who makes this project a labor of
love Thank You Jackie and then I'd like
to thank all of you again for making ICF
J's great work possible we look forward
to seeing you a year from now as we move
into our next quarter century of
advancing quality journalism worldwide
George Thank You Joyce thanks again to
all of you for making this such a
success tonight if you filled out a
donation card please hand it to an IC FJ
staff member on your way out we have to
keep pushing for that money all the way
so I cfj can thrive for another 25 years
and on behalf of everyone at ICF J
including the thousands of journals we
work with every year thanks for making
this evening such such a success and
let's leave with one final round of
applause for Sal shoo shoo sigh and
David thank you